[Música]
hablamos de salud por supuesto esta
mañana de martes en directo América de
France 24 y más Romero Sale está con
nosotros en el estudio mar bienvenida
buena mañana Hoy vamos a hablar de un
tema bien interesante vamos a hablar de
las bacterias y de su protagonismo la
muerte de millones de personas en todo
el mundo más buenos días Raúl si vamos a
hablar de eso porque hay nuevos datos
como siempre que traemos aquí en esta
Crónica de salud es la primera vez que
se hacen estimaciones globales de las
muertes asociadas a las bacterias más
comunes y la verdad es que los
resultados deberían hacer sonar las
alarmas de varios gobiernos y también de
los investigadores de la comunidad
científica en todo el mundo contamos
13,7 millones de muertes por infecciones
en general de estas más de la mitad de
77,7 perdón están relacionadas con
infecciones bacterianas comunas 33
bacterias que los investigadores de este
estudio que se publicó un delante están
recogido como las más comunes y las más
peligrosas también particularmente hay
cinco bacterias que destacan que son
estos nombres tan extraños que ven aquí
en sus pantallas todas estas cinco son
culpables del 30,9% de estas 13 millones
de muertes que les estábamos comentando
y más de la mitad también de las
infecciones por ejemplo el primero que
se llama estafilococo Dorado en nuestro
idioma digamos traducido eso ha causado
en solo en 2019 más de un millón de
muertes Raúl es un bichito de 1,5
micrómetros eso es una milésima parte de
un milímetro para que nos hagamos una
idea y puede infectar además básicamente
cualquier parte de nuestro cuerpo no
Además estas cifras que tenemos ahora
sobre la mesa hacen que el conjunto de
estas 33 bacterias si se suma sean la
segunda causa de muertes de todo el
mundo por detrás de las enfermedades de
corazón es importante decir que hay
algunas limitaciones con las cifras
simplemente por ejemplo se han recogido
datos de forma algo desiguales según las
regiones del mundo y también no se
distingue si la infección es la causante
de la muerte o participó la enfermedad
de la persona sin embargo más allá de
esto realmente da una imagen muy
panorámica de este problema del cual no
sabemos tanto no hay una cifra alarmante
13.7 millones de muertes Esto bueno
cifras del año 2019 pero que seguramente
se han mantenido más o menos en el
promedio hasta este año no hay que ver
qué dicen las cosas expertas ante esto
es tomar Pues mira nosotros para
hacernos una idea más general también
consultamos media Center de España que
recoge las opiniones de varios expertos
sobre los estudios que se publican y hoy
en día o sea en este momento estábamos
recogiendo van a escuchar la reacción de
un microbiólogo de la Universidad de
Barcelona escuchemos
el presente estudio permite reflexionar
sobre algunas cuestiones actuales acerca
de la consideración que presta nuestra
sociedad a las infecciones y de los
recursos que se dedican a combatir
algunas de ellas por ejemplo solo los
dos primeros patógenos causaron muchas
más muertes que el sida en 2019 pero los
recursos económicos destinados a luchar
contra Esta última enfermedad fueron
casi 50 veces superiores que los
destinados a controlar las infecciones
por e.coli para seguir comentando Raúl
hay varios puntos importantes el primero
como decía esta opinión es que esta
carga de enfermedad es mucho superior es
muy superior a por ejemplo otras
enfermedades como el VIH sin ir más
lejos el mismo Kobe 19 no que tiene
muchísimo más atención también
muchísimos más recursos y mucha
investigación y nos debería pues hacer
preguntar dónde estamos poniendo nuestra
atención y si lo estamos haciendo bien o
no y segundo también las diferencias
entre los países no detrás de estas
cifras absolutas hay unas tasas de
mortalidad que muestran muchísima
desigualdad por ejemplo República
centroafricana tiene la ta calidad más
baja Isla más alta Perdón Islandia tiene
la tasa de mortalidad más baja en la
diferencia entre ellas es que la de
República centroafricana multiplicaba
hasta por 100 la tasa de mortalidad de
Islandia eso tiene mucho que ver por
ejemplo con la prevención con los
recursos también con el estado de salud
de la población general que hace con una
infección pues pueda ser distinta en una
persona más sana que una persona que no
esté tan buen estado de salud y tercero
la famosa resistencia a los antibióticos
no sabemos que a medida han pasado los
años y las bacterias cada vez luchan más
contra los tratamientos que conocemos
para para tratarlas y pues no se
investiga principalmente porque no dan
tanto dinero en un tratamiento con
antibióticos te lo tomas una semana y ya
está sano Entonces pues no hay tanto
interés en encontrar alternativas a eso
eso Bueno pues con estas cifras y estas
reflexiones nos hace de nuevo eso pensar
que deberíamos estar haciendo
verdaderamente frente a este problema
que nos vamos a encontrar en el futuro y
el llamado como siempre a no
automedicarnos ser responsables con
nuestra salud y siempre acudir a nuestro
especialista más vamos a cambiar de tema
ahora para hablar lo que se conoce como
llamado gas de la risa Sí es que las
autoridades de consumo de drogas de
Europa el monitoreo de drogas han
lanzado una alerta por el consumo de lo
que se llama óxido nitroso conocido como
gas de la risa de hecho el reporte lo
titulan que no es motivo de risa en una
broma que podemos debatir si nos hace
risa a nosotros o no pero bueno
escuchamos lo que decían
el alza en el uso recreativo el óxido
nitroso en varias partes de Europa es
una causa de preocupación hay una
percepción generalizada sobre los
usuarios que inhalar óxidos nitroso es
seguro sin embargo vemos que un uso más
frecuente incrementa los riesgos de
daños peligrosos como afectaciones en el
sistema nervioso por lo tanto es
importante evitar normalizarlo o
promocionar su uso sin quererlo Qué es
este óxido nitroso preguntabas Raúl y lo
contamos ahora para todo el mundo no es
un gas que de hecho se usa para muchas
cosas se distribuye con cierta
normalidad por ejemplo se usa como una
especie de sedante para intervenciones
mínimas por ejemplo dentales no cuando
nos tienen que hacer algo pues el
dentista también se usa para aditivos en
los alimentos Entonces es algo que se
usa en nuestro día a día Pero que es
verdad que también tiene algunos efectos
psicoactivos Como por ejemplo una
sensación de euforia o de relajación de
una cierta corta duración No no es nuevo
que Se use con fines recreativos pero el
consumo ha aumentado últimamente porque
es es fácil de conseguir y Además a eso
se puede vender como en unos cartuchos
que estábamos viendo antes en las
pantallas que son fáciles como unos
inhaladores y además eso hay esa
sensación de que es inoco de que no nos
hace daño no también por esa corta
duración pero a la larga y con mucho uso
puede llegar a intoxicar puede llegar a
provocar quemadura en los pulmones
porque este gas viene muy frío no Y
también puede inactivar la vitamina B12
en el organismo que es especialmente
importante para nuestras funciones
neurológicas bueno Y evidentemente esto
no está pues hecho para nuestro consumo
exactamente Cuáles son los datos de
consumo hablando de este consumo no
lamentable
Sí pues no son tan claros cuando lo
vemos en total el reporte de la agencia
Europea de las drogas analizaba casos de
varios países europeos y les traemos
algunos ejemplos vemos que por ejemplo
en Dinamarca 1673 en Francia 10 134 Un
aumento exponencial de este consumo
Tendremos que estar atentos estar
atentos sumar Muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información de salud
mañana Por supuesto más mañana con